la manifestation est officiellement
interdite mais près du métro juste coût
10 au centre de moscou
la foule grossit à vue d'oeil en ce
samedi après midi tout le monde frappe
des mains en attendant le coup d'envoi
officiel honda poutine c'est notre but
libérez les prisonniers politiques
leur slogan varient et s'enchaînent
alors que la foule se déplace lentement
vers la place pouchkine est quelque part
dans cette marée humaine se cache celle
qui a lancé l'appel à la mobilisation
tous les filles à masquer riche que pato
le coach rien reçu et politique propre
ils ratent tout boosté par un petit but
politique contre lui téléphone à la main
elle filme tous ses déplacements
lioubov sobol 31 ans et infatigable est
dans la mire du kremlin shi avocat de
formation lui bob ce vol était candidate
aux élections prévues dimanche avant que
son dossier soit rejetée comme l'ont été
ceux de 60 autres indépendants la même
fallu à sortir de force des bureaux du
comité électoral
depuis c'est elle qui mène la fronde
contre la répression politique qui selon
masha lipman est devenue la norme en
russie mais municipal c'est surtout le
voisin devriez mascotte grenoble a dont
je dois passer ses diplômes pas dire je
gagnais je voudrais tenir
ça fait des années qu'elle se bat en
coulisses au nom de la liberté
elle n'avait que 23 ans quand elle s'est
jointe comme juriste aux militants
alexina vanille
enquêter sur la corruption au sein des
sociétés d'état son mari sergueï volkov
sociologue a même été agressé à la
seringue alors qu'elle se penchait sur
les activités d'un proche du président
vladimir poutine
mais cela ne l'a pas empêché de
continuer à militer au publiquement elle
est le cerveau de la chaîne youtube
navalni live qui avec ses millions
d'abonnés se veulent antidote à la
télévision d'état quoique encore méconnu
du reste de la russie
elle dérange le kremlin she is the board
of the straight pacino des rois sauf que
yougov sobol demeure une des rares
figures de l'opposition qui n'a pas été
en prison quoique plusieurs fois arrêté
nos soit lisse si chasse comme sur cette
vidéo où elle filme les politiques
défense à pas chaque fois elle était
libérée sur le champ
car la loi russe interdit notre
isolement des mères de jeunes enfants
à moins d'un crime grave et elle a une
fille de 5 ans et la voilà quelques
jours des élections
défiant les policiers elle sera arrêtée
à nouveau et détenu quelques heures
toujours plus tard en sortant d'un
magasin mais l'intrépide avocat n'a pas
dit son dernier mot
elle se veut pour le moment le visage
d'un mouvement qui n'a aucun champ est
validé
je ne la connais pas assez pour la
considérer une leader 17 manifestants
mais je partage certainement sa colère
c'était fantastique
mais le simple fait de tenir tête aux
régimes en russie est un pari risqué
ces efforts et c'est qu'il a citées font
d'elle une force en présence
incontournable